you know if you if you think about
Carnegie Mellon and you really look at
its enormous impact for such a small
University on America and on the world
it has come about when people usually a
handful maybe even one person with great
vision of a better world has been
supported by somebody or some person to
go and take the world in a new direction
a little bit of money here goes a long
way and a lot of money here changes
lives and changes the way that we think
about what we do and changes our ability
to think about the future we change the
world and every single donation assists
us in changing the world we have an
ability to really allow people to think
out of the box to train people that they
got out of the box to support people who
do think out of the box Carnegie Mellon
code has reputation to not just stick to
the normal or the it's good standard
we'll take that and like okay what's the
next step can we make this even better
we go further where has it not been
taken yet and to be able to take that
and not to worry about financially
backing it oh my goodness there's just
no limits you are not even thinking in a
box anymore there is no box you're just
out there and right now it's getting
harder and harder to get the funding for
basic research and the funding agency
pressure is to move you away from even
proposing that and toward proposing more
safe ideas but that's not what society
needs that's not what sign its
breakthroughs come from one of the
problems we have in engineering and
public policy is finding ways to support
doctoral students to work on new and
emerging problems that nobody else has
really figured out are important we take
on high-risk projects that we talk
children and teachers around the world
they mean inventing whole new
technologies it didn't exist and so it's
incredibly important for us that we have
money that doesn't have strings attached
that we're not doing deadlines and
milestones just for their own sake or
for the donors sake but rather we have a
global mission that's truly valuable to
us it's important for people to
understand how arts and technology
exists in a feedback with each other and
how supporting the Arts even for these
very small amounts can lead to
innovations that propel technology
further the profile culture further I'm
really grateful to Ray and Stephanie for
the funding that they gave to the
University to create the land chair and
the lane center I think that the value
of a scholarship is incredible for the
confidence that it gives both the
student for the work that he's doing and
the work that he's going to do and I
think for me it was really an
inspiration these people that have other
kind of their heart helping students
they've never met before the trusting
seeing you to give these scholarships to
who they feel best fit for them and just
going it just doing it that's so cool
when you more people like this in this
world if I can change someone else's
life like my life has been changed then
I feel like life is successful at that
point when you change someone else's
life you don't know the impact that
you've had on my life and I don't even
know and I won't know until you know
these these years are up but I would
just say thank you and shake his or her
hand and smile maybe even give him a hug
I think I give a mug too